à 5 jours de la présidence française de
l'Union européenne Jacques shirac est en
visite d'État en Allemagne le président
emboî le pas à Yoska Fischer le chef de
la diplomatie allemande en approuvant
l'élaboration d'une Constitution
européenne sur place Véronique
saintolive la porte de brandbourg à
Berlin c'est l'image de la réunification
de l'Allemagne Jacques shirac a choisi
d'y aller à pied en prenant son temps
parce que lors d'une visite d'État tout
est symbole et qu'aujourd'hui dans le
cadre de l'Europe le président de la
République veut renforcer encore les
liens entre l'Allemagne et la
France avec les jeunes de l'Université
de Berlin le chef de l'État a parlé de
l'Europe de demain celle qui pourrait
dans les 2 ans fonctionner avec une
Constitution pour savoir enfin qui fait
quoi mais pour le chef de l'État
l'Europe c'est avant tout le garant de
la paix soyez certain qu'il n a pas
d'alternative en terme de paix et en
terme de
démocratie ni d'ailleurs en terme de
progrès à la construction européenne et
qu'il n'y aura pas de construction
européenne sans un moteur quelqu'un a
utilisé ce mot
franco-allemand qui fonctionne bien à la
veille de prendre la présidence
française Jacques Chirac doit s'exprimer
tout à l'heure devant le Bundestag son
objectif est clair c'est avancer avec
l'Allemagne sur les dossiers concret
mais c'est surtout préparer avec elle
l'avenir de l'Europe une Europe qui sera
élargie et une Europe qui devra être
plus
forte